>>> .
DERAL ECHAVE
ARGET OF
TIONTHUMISIN
ANIAL DIOU REALLHIS
POINT.
ALSO E LANNING  BRIG A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF ANY
CHARGEINAT A FEDERAL FLORIDA.
INK ABOU
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS IN A
MOMENT.
I WANT TO BEGI REID. ARE YOU LE?
THT UMBEEN INFORMED THAT HE IS
DOCUMENTS.N THAT
OSD BE MOVING
CLOSERSSIBLY INDICTING THE
.
LEGALEAM
WAS IN VIS NORM THE FOCUS OF
IS INVESTITILTIPLE
SOURCES HAVERNIT DESCRIBED TEM,S
HAVE DIRECTLY ORSONALL
ITEAY CRLIE FACT ATOUK
THIS INVEIGISCUSED ME
TRUMP AND NOT JUST T PEOPLE
AROU H.
USUALLY, IF U CIENTT
ANS THOU
U WOULD LIKE
A GRAND JURY.
IT DOEEMY AT LEGAAM.AS H RD DO ,
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT EARLIER THIS
BELIEVE ARE
AND, AS WE KW,MER
PRESENS HAHE ON GETTING SOME
BREAKING DETAILS ABOUTVE
BANNON, ANHER
IGATION ABOUT JANUARY 6th.
WHAT'S THAT?
>>orHAS E SPECIASEL'S
INRYth
WE'VE LEARNED THAT FORMEWHITE
HOUSE ADVISE TRUMP
ALLY STEVE BANNOBEEN
BEONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.FOR
SO IT'UNE'G TO BALL.
HE ALSO HAS THE OPPORTUNIFCHOOS
SIGNIFICANT WITNESR THEMO WE OFE
COATWIESEAE  B
THISHAT THINVESTIGATORS IN.
JANUARY IO
SPOKE WITH ALYSSA SA
O BEFORE THE GRAND
JURY.
ONE OF THE T LEARNED IS  INVESTV
INTERESTED IN TRUMP'S STATE OF
MIND.
R   TTHAT NDARY 6t
6th INVESTAT P AASNG ABOUT RIGHY
DOS ND OBVIOUSLY THAT IS A
QUON THESE IF
THEY COME TOGETHER, AND THOSE I.
THANK YOU SOUCALYSSA FARAH GRI
TO SPEO PRECS SHE
ALWAYS DOES IN HERE,O
EQR.T" NOW, FORMER TRUMP
E PRESS SECRETARY, ANDE FORMER
RYAN, LET ME START WITH THE VERR
TRUMINRMED T
TARGET OF THE OBVIOUSLY IT'S --P
KNE
BU DKNOWT
HET .W GNS STEP PROCEDURALLY?
>> WE BOTH THOUGHT THAT THAT I
THE CASE AE REASON
BECAUSE HE WAS INVGATING
TT
DONT MGET?DUSIFIEDERE'S
O
ESTIGATHERE'S NO WS TOR G TOLD T
E CONTTO
ALERT  SOWT  HE EEN HIWYICPA DOR
MONDAY.
JO, E
TERMSEN
U.S. ATTORNEY ITITY  SISTANTJUS.
UAVISE T
COUNSEL, MAYBE YOU
THINT BET.SE APPTHK FOR AN UNA S
MISCDU ANCES THAT  M ROCU
DEPARTMENT OF THE ECHAS HO GUME
EY GENER.
CAPRE A RECODAICK RL
SON'T LOOK LIKE THATE CLOSING U
TARGET MEANSBELIEVE THAT ARE.
RYIDENCE BY
GUILTY BEYOND A REONABLE
NTION THE STANDARD THERE
IONSOTOLDE G IN
OF COURSE THE RTING IS OTHERWIS.
DO YOU  O
IT?
>> WELL, IT'S TYPICAL TRUMP,
OF THE STORY DEN.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS INTERESS T LO
THINGS HE'S BEEN
WHICH OBVIOUSLY IN
COMMUNICATIONST LISTING THNEGAT.
C TO DO THAT.
ALLY, IT HIT MTHAT
KNOW, I'M INNDOUGHT, AIN
IS GOING TNTE ALOFUES HE'S HAVIN
THINK IT'S BIG CONSPIRAC
>> SO, R PAULA IS GGTHAT BMING O
THE JANUARY 6 TE CLASSIFIED DU
DON'T COME TOGETHER.
DO YOU SEE WAY, AND W
DOES THAT PLAY OUTENY SEE IF TH.
BYLL ACCOUNTS, A REPORTS THEMAR
JUST TO BETHOB ALSPI
E IDEA THAT TODAY WE GHTT KNOW
BANNON RECTLIT'S AE SHOCKIHAWO
COMMITTEE IDENED
CE VESTIGATION.
T
LATE, WHIST HAPPENING W?
>> FEDERAL GRAND JURY IN
SOFLORIDA,OURACTICE LAW THIS.
DO  A SIGNIFICANT OUNT OF CHARGE
MAR-A-LAGO SILO THAT WE'RELDE B.
TH
>> THIS MAI BETTER TRUMP.ONAL F
TURNED IN-DE
FAIT WILL NOMIAMI-DADE
COUNTY.
D JU N GY,'S ANOTHER GRAND
N AMT H GREY DON'T SITN PALM BE
USE VID THERS
TO SIINT'S , THIS WILL BE A
PALM BEA COUNTY CASE WHERE THE .
EDY ON
NSTITUTION THAT LL PROTECTD IT L
AND IF TED,E
PRES I GOVERNMENT WHS VE HIMLTDF
AIRED OUT IF HE'CT
SO INK AR TRIA ALL
>> AE LLINT TPO I OLDING IT.
>> EVERYBODY HASY WE DON'T
WAVIOLENCE.
CAN ONLY HE
WHETHIS
SS I ANCI
E VISLOWLY HERE THAN THE DOCEN -
CASE AT  YI HAVE VOLUNRI
COOPERATED WITH TH
IGATION.
>> ALL
N, JUST  M
COMING FFLORIDA,S TIFIED I ONE
IT COME FROMTON?
IT SOUNDS LIKE MAYBEHEH PAULFOR
OF GRAVIE IN E ESPIONE D BE I
FLORIDA.
.HERE DID HE RETN
>> WHAT WAS YOUR EXP
S, DID THEIR
DEMEANOREIESSION
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU CAN SHARE?
WAS DISCOBVIOUSLY, I AGREE WITH
GUEST THAT IS INNTPROVEN GUILTYC